if you're tired of your bank ripping you
off click the link below to learn about
our sponsor current which is an awesome
alternative to dealing with big banks
I'll tell you more about them at the end
of the video so let me get to sort of a
a tour of reactions to Donald Trump's
claim that he's taking
hydroxychloroquine prophylactically
again I don't know that we believe it
Trump shouldn't be taking it but he also
may be lying by talking about it he's
creating he has already created a
shortage for people who actually need
this medication for approved uses like
lupus and malaria
it's unproven as a coronavirus
prophylactic and Trump doesn't have any
of the conditions that this drug has
actually approved to treat but he claims
to be taking it so last night Nancy
Pelosi Democratic Speaker of the House
says listen this drug has adverse
reactions under the sort of cardiac
umbrella and Trump's morbidly obese so
he shouldn't be taking it take a look at
this as far as the president is
concerned the arteries are president and
I would rather he not be taking
something that has not been approved by
the scientists especially in his age
group and in his shall we say weight
group had but it is morbidly obese they
say so I I think that was it's not a
good idea so this immediately triggered
a whole span of reactions some people
gleefully going all the way up to
bordering on fat shaming Trump other
people reacted furious that Nancy Pelosi
would be making such baseless claims
about Trump's morbid obesity so let's go
through this item-by-item
hydroxychloroquine has a number of
adverse effects it includes cardiac
arrhythmias hypoglycemia and a number of
neuropsychiatric effects if you have a
cardiovascular deficiency which Donald
Trump does he is overweight we'll talk
about obesity in a moment this is a drug
you should probably avoid unless totally
necessary it's clearly not necessary for
Donald Trump to take this if he is
indeed taking it now it also causes a
bunch of neuropsychiatric symptoms it
includes agitation insomnia confusion
mania hallucinations paranoia depression
catatonia psychosis suicidal ideation
what's interesting about that is Trump
already exhibits a whole bunch of those
so we may not even be able to tell the
difference Trump is regularly agitated
he claims to sleep only a few hours a
night
he's regularly confused his Twitter use
is completely manic he's completely
paranoid you get the idea so now we get
to the question is Pelosi right that
Trump is morbidly obese Trump claims to
be six foot three inches tall and
weighed 239 pounds that would put you
out of BMI of twenty nine point nine the
line for obesity is thirty now I know
BMI is very flawed but for most people
you know Trump is not a bodybuilder for
example where BMI doesn't work it's a
pretty good rule of thumb
so the suspicion is Trump claims to be
6-3 to 39 because that puts him
literally one pound from being obese and
we know Trump is not six foot three
inches tall you can look at Trump in
pictures with other people whose Heights
we know for example Justin Trudeau the
Canadian Prime Minister is six foot two
Trump is clearly shorter than Trudeau in
pictures and we've got a bunch of
examples so if Trump is 6 1 and 239 he's
obese Trump is more likely 6 1 and 260
he is higher in obesity however he is
not morbidly obese usually we use some
combination of your a hundred pounds
overweight you have a BMI above forty or
a BMI above 35 with obesity related
conditions like diabetes or blood
pressure Trump even at 6 1 to 60 has a
BMI of 34 point three so listen guys
Nancy Pelosi was wrong Donald Trump is
not morbidly obese by any reasonable
definition he is certainly obese and he
should not be taking prophylactic
hydroxychloroquine so that gets us once
again back to the question of is Trump
really taking it what doctor would
prescribe for an older obese guy with a
heart problem
something that is ineffective in
preventing coronavirus and increases the
rate of cardiac arrhythmia final
takeaway is we don't know whether Trump
is on this and we may never know but
fortunately at least one Fox News host
is sounding the alarm about what Donald
Trump claims to be doing
it's no secret on the show that I am
very critical of the big banks and how
they screw over customers in so many
ways and if you're like me you're
probably sick of the fees and the
hassles that come with a checking
account at a big traditional bank by now
in that case check out the online bank
current they're one of our sponsors if
you're watching on YouTube this here is
my actual debit card for my current
checking account which I'm holding up
with current you've got no minimum
balance no overdraft fees up to $100 no
ATM fees you can use over fifty five
thousand ATMs nationwide unlike with
other banks you receive your direct
deposit instantly meaning you'll get
paid by your employer up to two days
sooner you can deposit checks instantly
using your camera phone 24/7 member
support and unlike with other banks
current instantly refunds that hold on
your card when you pump gas
you can pause your debit card instantly
which is really useful there are just so
many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes
two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video